Christopher dure avec la ministre
Catherine Colin a donc annoncé la
livraison de matériel militaire de la
France à l'Arménie vous saluer cette
décision la France est à la hauteur dans
ce confort je pense qu'elle est
extrêmement en retard surtout moi si
vous voulez je titre d'exemple je leur
donne Bardet est déjà intervenu au
Parlement européen début 2022 pour
évoquer la faiblesse de l'Union
européenne
dans cette crise
en fait on a aujourd'hui une diplomatie
qui est tenue par la perte de
souveraineté de la France en matière
énergétique notamment c'est-à-dire que
comme on est dépendant de l'Azerbaïdjan
en matière gazir notamment bah forcément
on est tenu aussi en matière
diplomatique du fait de se faire
forcément une intervention qui est
extrêmement tardive parce qu'on a en
fait plus d'autre choix si vous voulez
quand mais la France intervient c'est le
pays de l'Union européenne qui
intervient le plus oui mais encore une
fois je pense très tardivement il y
aurait sans doute fallait le faire bien
en amont je pense que c'est aussi il
faut faire quoi il faut rompre le compte
le contrat de gaz entre l'Union
européenne et l'Azerbaïdjan il faut
surtout qu'on récupère notre
souveraineté notre capacité à produire
du gaz ça fait des années que Marine Le
Pen soulève que la France n'est plus en
capacité de produire ni son électricité
ni songaz et forcément ça nous rend
moralement dépendant d'autres puissances
et aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on en
intervient beaucoup très tardivement en
Arménie autre sujet d'actualité Emmanuel
Macron et ce matin devant le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est aujourd'hui les 65
ans de notre Constitution qu'est-ce que
vous attendez du chef de l'État
notamment en élargissement de l'article
11 pour ouvrir le champ du référendum on
l'attend mais je sais pas si on l'aura
parce que finalement je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron
aime bien une plastronome mais qu'il
agit jamais réellement et aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on a besoin d'un
élargissement du champ de compétence de
je suis pas vraiment convaincu je pense
qu'en fait ils ont vraiment peur de la
démocratie directe c'est-à-dire que
finalement ils ont peur d'être tenus par
la décision du peuple et qu'il préfère
on le voit notamment dans la manière de
gérer les débats à l'Assemblée nationale
il préfère toujours le passage en force
donc si vous voulez se soumettre
décision du peuple directement à des
sites des décisions qui paraissent
j'allais dire irréfragable irrévocable
je pense je pense pas qu'ils aient
forcément envie de s'y soumettre mais là
il en a parlé lui-même de
l'élargissement de cet article 11 du
référendum vous n'y croyez pas je sais
pas il a parlé très longtemps de de
réformes institutionnelle de réforme des
modes de scrutin notamment pour le les
élections législatives de la
proportionnelle etc finalement les a
jamais vu venir donc je pense que encore
une fois il y a beaucoup de postures
mais qu'on verra bien les actes
demain aura lieu le Conseil national de
la refondation post-emute autour
d'Elizabeth borne là aussi qu'est-ce que
vous attendez comme mesure de la part de
la première ministre j'attends de la
fermeté mais je pense pas que ça viendra
deux encore une fois parce que on voit
qu'on a encore dans l'excuse sociale
notamment
moi si vous voulez typiquement la
politique de la ville moi je suis
adjoint Hénin-Beaumont depuis maintenant
10 ans notamment en charge des questions
d'urbanisme et des questions sociales
la politique de la ville j'en connais
les limites alors c'est sûr que ça
intervient parfois dans des quartiers
prioritaires où on en a bien besoin mais
pas forcément si vous voulez c'est
toujours une espèce de Cotter sur jambe
de bois finalement où on fait de la
politique de guichet mais sans jamais
s'attaquer réellement aux causes des
problématiques je pense qu'il y a un
besoin de fermeté une question de
reconquête de certains territoires
c'est-à-dire à la fois je pense une
renforcement des sanctions pénales
notamment quand on identifie les
situations comme celle-ci je pense qu'il
y a une question de responsabilisation
des parents parce qu'on a bien vu que
les émeutiers pour la plupart étaient
très jeunes et qui a si ce n'est de la
complicité au moins de la faiblesse des
parents
c'est parfois une assume pas réellement
proposez ça peut être ça notamment après
on peut toujours être une réponse pour
vous ça peut être une partie de réponse
honnêtement ça paraît que si vous voulez
comme espèce de devoir fondamental quand
on touche les allocations familiales
finalement que de de
d'avoir un minimum de succès dans
l'éducation de ses enfants il peut y
avoir aussi parfois des parents qui sont
très bien intentionnés et qui n'arrivent
plus à maîtriser leurs enfants ça peut
exister ça c'est des situations qu'on
sait identifié aujourd'hui si vous
voulez je pense que c'est la plupart du
temps dans l'éducation du coup c'est
pour qui la suppression des élèves
honnêtement on le voit régulièrement si
vous voulez qu'on vous avez un un
adolescent qui est déjà multi
récidiviste c'est qu'il y a forcément un
échec des parents la plupart du temps on
identifie les situations relativement
jeunes dans le parter scolaire voilà je
veux dire c'est encore c'est une
situation qu'on sait la repérer sur
lesquels on doit agir en amont c'est là
peut-être qu'il peut y encore y avoir un
petit peu de prévention en revanche
après il va forcément je pense une
forfaiture parfois de certains parents
avant-hier Emmanuel Macron a annoncé
l'implantation de 238 nouvelles brigades
de gendarmerie à travers tout le
territoire vous saluez cette annoncé une
bonne réponse à la délinquance dans le
milieu rural c'est un début je pense pas
que ce soit suffisant je pense dans
votre département également oui oui on a
priori 4 dans mon département d'après ce
que l'on sait mais oui typiquement j'ai
pas été saisi par les services de l'État
pour nous clarifier ce qui allait être
fait si vous voulez donc en fait j'ai
une espèce de vision très parcellaire de
ce qui a été annoncé
c'est un début de réponse simplement
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a besoin
d'un quadrillage réel du territoire
quand je parle un quatrième c'est pas
militaire si vous voulez mais je pense
qu'il y a besoin
de ça le département du Pas-de-Calais
typiquement est un appartement
extrêmement vaste là on parle de quatre
nouvelles brigades je suis même pas sûr
que ce soit suffisant parce que dans le
même temps on a besoin de renforcement
des effectifs de police nationale en
zone urbaine je pense qu'il y a aussi
besoin peut-être de renforcer la
porosité si vous voulez entre la police
et la gendarmerie dans leur capacité
d'intervention le problème si vous
voulez c'est que le parfum du principe
que quand vous mettez des moyens de
police quelque part ou de ou de
gendarmerie la délinquance ou la
criminalité se déplace font donc pouvoir
agir partout sinon forcément vous créez
de nouvelles poches vous déplacez le
problème finalement c'est peut-être pas
non plus le travail mais là si vous
voulez je me permettrai simplement aussi
d'évoquer une problématique que j'ai pu
rencontrer
et à titre personnel comme adjoint en
mérides un Beaumont mais aussi dans le
cadre de ma campagne électorale il faut
qu'on arrête de demander aux mairies de
faire de la sécurité à la place de
l'État la sécurité reste une prérogative
de l'État il faut qu'on arrête si vous
voulez de compter systématiquement sur
les municipalités pour investir dans la
vidéoprotection pour recruter elle-même
des effectifs de police municipale je
pense qu'aujourd'hui chacun doit revenir
à son rôle c'est normal du coup il y a
plus de 2000 postes de gendarmes non
mais je pense avec ces brigades oui mais
je pense que ça reste encore une fois
assez faible
on va aller voir l'actualité du côté de
chez vous dans le Nord dans le
Pas-de-Calais on va à Lille dans le Nord
retrouver pierre Jérôme monteneau
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef ah oui oh c'est la
télévision locale du Nord pierre Jérôme
voulait revenir sur l'élection
sénatoriale qui a compris Christopher
Juret au Palais du Luxembourg
et oui bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour
monsieur durek vous avez doublé votre
score rose au sénatorial par rapport à
2017 vous avez été chercher des voies
au-delà de ce qui est un peu l'électorat
traditionnel
urbain dans des zones en difficulté
est-ce que ça veut dire que maintenant
vous êtes en train de réussir
l'implantation dans les campagnes et
dans les bourses oui je pense qu'il y a
quand même de ça mais si vous voulez moi
je ce qui m'a vraiment beaucoup frappé
c'est un peu la excusez-moi la côte de
popularité de nos députés depuis
maintenant un an et demi on savait qu'on
a six députés maintenant la moitié des
députés du Pas-de-Calais sont des
députés rassemblements national pour la
plupart implanter évidemment dans les
circonscriptions relativement rurales en
fait les gens se sont habitués à
travailler avec nous et donc ils nous
voient aussi tel qu'on est réellement et
pas en fonction si vous voulez ou de
stéréotypes ou de préjugés ou quoi que
ce soit en fait c'est sûr que ça aidait
à casser un peu les clivage moi je l'ai
bien vu dans les élus qui ont pu me
recevoir que j'ai pu rencontrer sur le
teint qui m'ont témoigné parfois
ostensiblement leur sympathie il y a des
élus d'absolument tous les bords la
plupart du temps par carte c'est aussi
si vous voulez une tradition ruralité de
ne pas afficher si vous voulez son
étiquette politique et je trouve ça
absolument normal mais c'est à dire
qu'il y a élus des élus locaux pas
encartés mais plutôt de droite ou de
gauche qui ont voté POUR VOUS
clairement parfois des élus et c'est
aussi un phénomène des élections
municipales de 2020 c'est que les élus
sont beaucoup moins tenus par les
étiquettes politiques qu'avant
c'est-à-dire que vous avez parfois dans
des conseils municipaux de ville
socialistes etc des édus qui sont pas
qui ont été recrutés entre guillemets
dans la société civile qui sont pas
issus du serail politique et qui en fait
sont pas tenus aujourd'hui par des
consignes de vote particulière donc une
fois qu'on les retrouve dans l'isoloir
ils font absolument ce qu'ils veulent et
ça je pense qu'effectivement c'est où on
est allé les chercher absolument partout
mais vous n'avez pas retrouvé ni vous ni
votre collègue du nord de l'Escort des
députés dans les hauts de France non
parce qu'il reste encore un peu ce poids
de la politisation si vous voulez mais
partant du principe qu'on a réussi à se
faire élire que moi je double comme vous
le dites mais mais mais mes résultats
par rapport à 2017 si vous voulez dans
le Pas-de-Calais on a en gros 150 grands
électeurs cartés très clairement ça veut
dire que j'ai presque 400 voix qui
viennent d'ailleurs mais si vous voulez
cette réflexion je pourrais la retourner
dans l'autre sens c'est que le Parti
socialiste qui est encore de très
nombreuses communes
encore beaucoup d'exécutifs arrivent
tout juste derrière moi ça veut dire que
eux au contraire le Parti socialiste est
devenu aujourd'hui typiquement
uniquement la syndicat d'élus qui n'est
plus en mesure de rassembler alors que
ça a été si vous voulez la grande force
politique du Pas-de-Calais pour montrer
longtemps
il y avait une liste de gauche hein
mais c'est bien la preuve aussi si vous
voulez que les étiquettes ne tiennent
plus totalement les parties ne tiennent
plus totalement si vous voulez les
grands électeurs et c'est sans doute
heureux
merci Pierre Jérôme merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous merci à très vite
évidemment dans cette émission
Christopher Duret on le disait vous
faites partie des trois nouveaux visages
du rassemblement national au Sénat
sénateur du Pas-de-Calais votre terre
familiale mais vous n'êtes pas un novice
en politique Steve Jourdain viendrai
c'est votre portrait
[Musique]
vous êtes un pur produit du
rassemblement national on va en parler
dans quelques instants vous avez 38 ans
vous êtes un eni noir pur jus alors un
nidois pour pour expliquer un peu c'est
un habitant de la ville d'Hénin-Beaumont
dans le Pas-de-Calais cette commune qui
est dirigée depuis 2000 et 14 par le
maire RN Steve Briois dont vous êtes un
très proche dans la ville vous
connaissez tout le monde il faut dire
que et bien votre famille est très bien
implantée arrière petit-fils de Polonais
arrivé en France dans les années 20 fils
d'ouvriers qui vote Arlette Arlette
Laguille où il a trop de ski elle
élection présidentielle de 1995 vous non
plus vous n'avez pas toujours été à
l'extrême droite en 2002 vous descendez
même dans la rue contre un certain
Jean-Marie Le Pen pour lui faire barrage
au deuxième tour de la présidentielle
plus de 20 ans plus tard c'est sa fille
qu'on va voir Marine Le Pen qui fait le
déplacement à Arras elle vient le jour
du scrutin des élections sénatoriales
pour personnellement vous apporter son
soutien et que s'est-il passé entre
2002-2023 et bah Christoph er Zurek a
entendu une voix au plus tôt un discours
monsieur le sénateur celui de Jean-Marie
Le Pen on est en 2006 le vieux menhir
vient prononcer à Valmy un discours à
l'endroit même où l'armée
révolutionnaire a mis en déroute l'armée
prussienne en 1792 écoutez
je suis venu vous annoncé qu'un nouveau
Valmy nous attend nouvelle menace
nouveau défi trouver l'espoir pour que
continue l'histoire d'une France forgée
à la grandeur de Vercingétorix à
Saint-Louis
de Gaulle ou bien qu'elle disparaissent
dépêcher Annie il est englouti dans le
magma Europe Atlantis oui à
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce est
soumise à l'euthanasie de l'automne
et aujourd'hui Christopher Zurich
incarne le rassemblement le nouveau
visage du rassemblement national oui le
rassemblement national en cravate comme
le souhaite Marine Le Pen un discours
toujours aussi fort sur certains thèmes
comme les migrations mais sans faire
trop de vagues en quartier depuis 2007
au Front national vous avez
progressivement gravi les échelons du
parti il y a dix jours on en parlait
tout à l'heure vous avez été élu dans
les terres populaires du Pas-de-Calais
par 557 voies de grands électeurs
14,12%, vous êtes incontestablement la
sensation la petite surprise de cette
élection normalement un scrutin
asseznatorial se fait dans une ambiance
plutôt feutrée il va pas avec vous
regardez
[Applaudissements]
vous avez marqué un but en finale de
Coupe du Monde c'est aussi votre style
vous venez ici pour casser les codes
pour être disruptif comme on dit je sais
pas si c'est exactement ça d'ailleurs il
y a plusieurs choses sur lesquelles je
voudrais revenir bien d'abord à je ne
suis toujours pas l'extrême droite ça
c'est pour la ce que vous avez pu
annoncer en tout début de dernière
intervention deuxième chose
d'État
en gros il le désapprouve pas le fait
que le ministère de l'Intérieur
moi je défends depuis toujours et depuis
mon adhésion aux Front national le
nidrote ni gauche qui était qui date
d'ailleurs si vous voulez cette alors
certains pour appeler ça une posture
pour moi je le prends presque comme une
hygiène de vie ça date même d'avant
Marine Le Pen si vous voulez ni droite
nigaud Front national c'est un slogan
qu'on entendait déjà dans les premiers
mais il y a très longtemps pour le reste
pour revenir vite fait sur le discours
de Valmy il y avait quelque chose
beaucoup plus important et c'est ce qui
m'avait parlé dans le discours de Valmy
c'est l'appel de Jean-Marie Le Pen aux
Français d'origine étrangère mais qui
s'était assimilé à rejoindre le Front
National et moi ça voulait bien durer
une chose c'était que le Front national
n'était pas attaché si vous voulez ni à
l'origine ni à l'ethnie à la couleur de
peau ou quoi que ce soit mais simplement
au sentiment de d'être français de
vouloir ouvrir dans l'intérêt général
et si vous voulez de s'assimiler
c'est-à-dire il y a comme on dit quand
tu vas à Rome vit comme les romans si
vous voulez moi c'est la vision de
Saint-Augustine mais pas l'héritage de
Jean-Marie Le Pen et si j'assume tout si
vous déjà j'adhère en 2007 j'adhère
après l'élection présidentielle de 2007
et après les élections législatives de
2007 si vous voulez moi je ne renie
absolument rien les gens avec lesquels
je je travaille avec lesquels je suis
ami depuis de longue date sont aussi
entre guillemets de vieux adhérents du
Front national je pense en particulier
évidemment si vrai Bruno Bill qui sont
des frères d'armes et j'allais dire
presque des frères tout court alors en
Brice Freddy Beaudin qui sont qui sont
des vraiment des très proches
pour autant vous parliez un petit peu
notre réaction le soir de l'élection on
était content on a assumé notre notre
bonheur si vous voulez d'avoir pour la
première fois un sénateur RN dans le
Pas-de-Calais on a laissé exprimer notre
joie j'ai fait une campagne de manière
très feutrée j'ai pas du tout attaqué
mes adversaires ils ont pas forcément
observé les mêmes disciplines à mon
égard mais moi si vous voulez je
disruptif sur le fond oui sur la forme
non j'ai pas envie de me comporter moi
comme la France insoumise à l'Assemblée
nationale
c'est-à-dire en histrion finalement où
je pense qu'il y a en fait beaucoup
d'opérations de com moi je vais
respecter l'institution je vais
respecter mes collègues même quand je
suis pas d'accord avec eux mais je voilà
je veux dire on va pas on va pas
renverser la table on va faire notre
travail de parlementaire non c'est ça en
tout cas du travail de fond avant tout
mais pas de voilà pas de travail sur le
fond peut-être il y aura cette migration
qui arrive au mois de novembre vous
dites que vous êtes mis droite ni gauche
quel sera votre position à ce à ce sujet
et elle est on dit sur la régul
organisation des travailleurs sans
papier ces miettes vous qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez typiquement je pense que
la régularisation des sans-papiers sert
des intérêts de gauche comme des
intérêts de droite enfin d'une certaine
gauche et d'une certaine droite
c'est-à-dire une gauche angéliste qui
essaye de se constituer un petit peu une
réserve électorale nouvelle espèce
d'armée de réserve électorale pour
reprendre les espèces de terminologie
marxiste et à côté de ça vous avez une
espèce de droite
un peu un peu un peu bourgeoise libérale
qui elle veut si vous voulez une arme de
dumping social pour faire pression à la
baisse sur les salaires nous on veut un
peu se placer au dessus de la mêlée je
pense que la question de l'immigration
elle est elle est sociale elle est
culturelle elle est un peu identitaire
et sécuritaire
ils veulent faire barrage vous vous
serez pas à leur côté si pourquoi pas il
y a pas de souci à ça moi je vous dis
encore une fois je suis pas secteur si
aussi ça va dans le bon sens et
d'ailleurs on voit que nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que là ça va
dans le bon sens de s'opposer à cet
article pour
ça va dans le bon sens mais c'est qu'une
partie si vous voulez de cette fois
immigration moi j'attends de voir ce que
ça va donner réellement typiquement sur
l'application des auqtf les obligations
de quitter le territoire français moi
après j'attendais si vous voulez en
amour il y a il y a que des preuves
voilà il y a les preuves c'est les actes
donc j'attends de voir je j'entends des
belles paroles mais j'attends de voir ce
que ça va vraiment donner si vous voulez
les lois sur l'immigration je pense
qu'on en a une tous les tous les 18 mois
j'attendras ce que ça va ce que c'était
une loi va donner on parle on parle
d'amour Stéphane Ravier était autrefois
rassemblant national il est passé à
reconquête il est aujourd'hui sénateur
vous lui dites quoi rejoignez-nous
maintenant revenez avec nous peut-être à
terme on pourra constituer un groupe pas
tout de suite évidemment non mais sans
sans évoquer le plan personnel et humain
suivez-moi j'ai rien contre Stéphane
ravi à titre personnel je pense qu'il a
commis une erreur et qu'il l'a commise
en plus au pire des moments c'est-à-dire
en pleine campagne présidentielle au
moment où on a besoin si vous voulez
d'une unité autour
d'une figure qui était légitimement
désignée qui était Marine Le Pen et je
l'espère sera encore Marine Le Pen en
2027 mais là vous allez travailler
comment avec lui vous l'avez rencontré
est-ce que vous allez travailler de
concert ou est-ce que vous aurez de de
c'est pas des groupes mais ça sera
chacun de son côté on parlera Stéphane à
l'ensemble de nos collègues
non pas particulièrement apprécié comme
un autre oui c'est ça après je pense que
je pense qu'il est pas vraiment parti
pour des raisons idéologiques quand il
est parti je pense que il y a toujours
dans ces cas là un tas de raisons
personnelles etc
avec vous avec d'autres sénateurs
notamment certains républicains vous
allez l'aider à le faire ou c'est pas
une bonne idée je pense que c'est un
coup de com d'une part moi je suis là
pour poursuivre au Sénat le travail
parlementaire de nos députés je suis
conçoit nous nous trois un peu comme le
prolongement du travail parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale il se trouve que
là on forme un groupe technique le
fameux rassemblement des non inscrits au
Sénat qui n'existe pas l'Assemblée
nationale dont j'ai été désigné délégué
hier soir
mais qui est un rôle technique
administratif il va me permettre
vous êtes trois dans une assemblée de
348 comment vous comptez peser au Sénat
je pense que à partir du moment où le RN
est présent dans une assemblée je vois
mal si vous voulez LR pouvoir continuer
à jouer ce rôle un peu trouble
mimidure si vous voulez sur certains
sujets je pense qu'on va les forcer un
petit peu à se positionner ça durcir oui
un peu de ça si vous voulez en tout cas
sur sur l'immigration les attend
forcément un petit peu donc vous êtes à
droite de la droite mais non si vous
voulez maintenant
d'une part si on procline thématique ça
veut rien dire parce qu'après il y a
tout culturel social etc une politique
c'est globale c'est pas c'est pas
parcellaire
mais si vous voulez encore une fois moi
j'attends de voir si on aura
si on appliquera cette cuménisme à notre
égard de la même manière que nous on
l'appliquera nos adversaires moi si vous
voulez tant qu'une solution me paraît
bonne pour nos compatriotes je la vôtrer
sans aucune difficulté et sans regarder
qu'il attient alors c'est pas le même le
même RA du côté de l'Assemblée nationale
puisque en ce moment il travaille sur
votre niche sur les textes de votre
niche c'est ce qui est réservé au groupe
et la majorité présidentielle à
l'Assemblée nationale a dit qu'elle ne
soutiendrait pas les textes de votre
niche notamment celui sur la
reconnaissance de la souffrance des
femmes victimes d'andrométriose c'est la
preuve que votre banalisation n'est pas
totale bon je pense surtout que il y a
tout un ensemble de pré carré politique
à préserver pour le pour l'exécutif pour
la majorité et qu'en fait et qu'on le
voit en gros ils disent qu'ils vont
qu'ils vont agir sur l'endométriose
parce que Marine Le Pen signait
intéressé d'une part c'est s'y intéresse
de longue date mais surtout ça veut dire
que même si ça se fait pas par la voix
directement législative on a quand même
des victoires culturelles et ça si vous
voulez si on n'était pas présent à
l'assemblée nationale et je pense que de
la même manière la question se poserait
si on n'était pas présent au Sénat on
pourrait pas forcément influer à ce
point sur le débat politique Olivier
Marleix
il semble dire que ce qui va dans le
sens des républicains même si ça vient
de vous il faut le voter
en amour il y a des preuves
on va voir ça demain si vous voulez mais
moi après je salue ça je pense aussi
qu'aujourd'hui les LR sont confrontés à
une question un peu de survie politique
je le cache pas je regrette aussi qu'ils
aient pas forcément eu cette ligne avant
quand il critique le position sur
l'immigration moi j'ai envie de leur
envoyer à ce qui était les positions sur
l'immigration du RPR dans les années 90
par exemple moi j'ai un peu envie que si
vous voyez qu'ils assument qu'ils
prennent leur courage à deux mains
encore une fois moi je peu importe d'où
viennent les soutiens tant que ça va
dans le sens des de l'intérêt des donc
au patriotes un dernier mot avant de se
quitter Christopher Gérard puisque vous
êtes du Pas-de-Calais sur la victoire de
Londres hier soir en Ligue des champions
qui a battu Arsenal comme vous avez
réagi
pas un footeux je vais pas vous le
cacher je vais pas le je vais pas jouer
la mieux disant ce footiste alors que je
suis pas vraiment grand connaisseur bon
c'est toujours une fierté non c'est
passé par de sombres épreuves ces
dernières années bon je pense que ça
même symboliquement moralement ça met un
petit peu de baume au coeur
bien sûr merci
beaucoup
pendant cette première demi-heure